[Musique]
il
je
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec hank de
faux bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes la
présidente de l'association jardins
passions partage c'est une association
qui est basé ici à guyancourt votre
jardin c'est quand même un des plus
beaux du coin qu'est ce que vous aimez
dans le jardinage j'aime bien cela
perdure mais elle peut fouiller un peu
de tout et bon ben c'est un peu dingue
dans mon jardin secret c'est un peu ma
personnalité
quand est ce que vous avez commencé à
jardiner une quinzaine d'années il d'une
vingtaine d'années mais quand c'est
arrivé dans la maison ici là je ne
savais pas du tout jardiner il savait
rien faire s'il ne s'agit pas planter
j'ai planté des choses à l'envers des
tomates chez pente et des chèvres
l'extérieur tout le monde se moquait de
moi puis au fur et à mesure où
j'apprends et j'apprends encore alors
pourquoi quand vous êtes arrivé ici sur
ce terrain vous avez décidé de planter
alors vous ne connaissez rien au début
c'est avec le terrain au début il n'y a
pas grand chose et la première chose que
j'ai planté ce sont les âpres
avec des fruits exotiques les kiwis les
cas qu'il est né plier les arbousiers au
début c'est déjà plus facile
puis après j'ai commencé un peu de fleur
puis au fur et à mesure après ben j'ai
appris avec des voisins des amis des
légumes
voilà ça commence comme cela et pourquoi
vous aviez plantes et des fruits
exotiques c'était pour voir les
consommer oui parce que j'ai rêvé
d'avoir un peu de fruits exotiques ne
cueillir et de manger sur place dans la
première qui est arrivé c'est ce que
j'ai fait
puis en plus et il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'entretien c'est pas comme des fleurs
ou des légumes
ces plantes et on attend qu'on attend
que ça pousse ça donne on attend combien
de temps alors est-ce que c'est long il
faut quand même à peu près cinq ans oui
mais la plantation vont attendre cinq
ans pour pouvoir comment c'était un
petit peu à la fois et quelle est la
dernière chose que vous avez planté
alors de me dire dans la dernière chose
qui est planté il ya trois quatre ans
un cas qui met une autre sorte de
quelques scènes kaki croquant on peut
manger quand ces croquants dans dés que
j'ai ici un cas qui il faut manger quand
c'est très dur c'est de sorts différents
d'accord il qu'est ce que vous en faites
de tout bon les fleurs c'est les fleurs
mais le reste vous consommez to be free
but d'accord je distribue beaucoup j'ai
fait venir les gens p
j'occupais après les gens viennent pour
distribuer les gens de mon âge aux
enfants un petit mail et après l'essai
de défiler des gens qui viennent
chercher des fruits donc vous distribuer
aux amis aux voisins aux membres de
l'association et voilà ça oui et vous
faites de la cuisine avec non pas trop
si je fais sécher pas les cas qui je
fais des guirlandes
jacques rocher après je me suis fait
social media il ya des bandes ont fait
des guirlandes quand ça c'est très bon
aussi et vous les utilisez emmanuel oui
on les mange sur les manches puis sinon
à l'automne on a des raisins on a plein
de raisins ont fait une bande blanche
non ok il ya une trentaine personnes qui
sont venues on coupe on met dans les
cageots après les faits au fait des jus
d'après certaines personnes qui ramène
les bouteilles de jus chez eux mais il
faut il fonde et de la gelée et la
dernière comme on pouvait pas faire le
mans donc sur entre nous il ya un
moustique est venu qui qui a faim de jeu
ici avec moi et après il a fait de la
gelée et après c'est j'ai vendu pour
téléthon les faire réparer les thons
pêchés pendule et les blés peau des
bébés et ben on en parlera justement du
téléthon donc je disais vous avez créé
l'association jardins passions partage
qu'est ce que vous y faites dans cette
association c'est des ateliers des
choses comme ça les ateliers des visites
des jardins la cuisine aussi
les jardins de qui ont cours quand je
vois un jardin de guyancourt qui est
assez intéressant
je demande si je peux offrir peu après
je double jardin il n'y a pas longtemps
le 12 juin l'an dernier c'est ouvrir un
jardin à guyancourt
donc c'est à dire que vous inviter les
personnes à venir dans son jardin dans
ce jardin d'accord
après on fait le guide et la probable le
propriétaire il fait visiter son jardin
c'était très bien c'est très bien aussi
c'est convivial c'est un échange d'idées
un peu mais voilà ça va recommencer
cuvée telle plante et voilà oui c'est
celui rendu par âge oui oui c'est ça
paie la fin s'il ya trop de plomb
distribue aussi lâché moi c'est pas les
gens viennent et après quand il pose
d'une pompe jeudi bon ben on va prendre
plus à cacher donne parce qu'il ya
tellement que bon ça ne me manque pas je
n'aurai de pour vous consoler et donc
justement vous en parliez grâce à
l'association fait aussi de la
solidarité notamment pendant le téléthon
ça fait de nombreuses années qui vont
participer et ont donc souvent vous
cuisinez vous proposer les repas la
vente et ensuite les fonds seront
reversés
pourquoi le téléthon en particulier
parce que c'était le ton qui est un peu
connu à guyancourt et c'est pour ça et
je connais les gens qui sont dans leur
association les autres années je fais
souvent des produits vont des tricots
des choses qu'on fait nous mêmes des
bricolages un peu mais je trouve que
c'est ça marche moins bien parce que les
gens n'achètent mois maintenant des
p'tit bazar tout ça alors la dernière on
a décidé de faire la cuisine
on a fait des plats à emporter on a fait
trois fois et à chaque fois ont eu une
centaine de menu les gens sont venus
commandés et après un bain après j'ai eu
quand même pas mal d'argent pour
téléthon l'année dernière et peuple et
3000 euros pour l'année à venir
c'est aussi le but de cette association
est partagée mais finalement aussi de
pouvoir donner derrière tu perces kg où
on partage marc clément qui ont partagé
par la passion de partager plus de se
voir
voilà et les produits pour que vous
aviez utilisé pour le téléthon dont il y
avait là la gelée et puis c'est des
choses que vous trouvez dans votre
jardin vous acheter ailleurs au ont fait
des courses société on n'a pas assez de
produits pour chez nous mais des fois
oui des fois quand je fais des mêmes
moules à celle là tu prends mon jardin
la montée j'en ai plein j'en arrache
c'est une forêt leur courage
je donne pour chaque repas je donne la
salle être l'amant de jardin et chez
vous vous manger les produits de votre
jardin uniquement en termes de fruits et
légumes un petit peu parce que chez moi
légèrement le potager c'est mélanger des
fleurs dont sa peau des mais enfin ça
produit pas beaucoup non plus mais c'est
le plaisir de voir une coursière qui
poussent entre les fleurs entre les
portes chanteur tout ça quoi mais bon
bain
je mange un peu sinon après j'ai des
voisins qui me donne aussi mais ça quand
le partager
de toutes ces rangées là il ya trois
quatre personnes qui nous qui m'apporte
des fruits des légumes on échange aussi
vous défendez embellir leur de même des
modèles à salades et légumes qu'après en
échange d'une chef des nains puis j'ai
déjà porté même puisque des fois je
donne aussi des oeufs de beppo de l'oci
parce que quand ça donne beaucoup après
on arrive pas tous finir car c'est ça
qui vous plaît c'est vraiment le partage
avec les habitants mais loin de voir les
gens discuter avec eux partager ce qu'on
a
mais quelle est la plante de votre
jardin que vous préférez c'est d afrique
et que j'aime bien c'est des fruits les
kakis j'adore les kakis pour la beauté
de l'art vous pour le goût la beauté de
l'art quand ça commence à sortir parce
qu'à l'hiver ni rien et commence à cinq
ans comment sortir les feuilles sont
vraiment raide ose prétendre d'une verve
mais vraiment très très joli et après
quand c'est l'automne mais il faut
deviennent un peu marre ont un peu brun
très jolie aussi c'est la beauté de la
delà de la peur les feuilles tous à peu
après ça donne des fruits en plus
toujours pas bougé on peut manger s'est
révolté si justement on peut faire
pousser des plantes qu'on appelle
exotique mais ici en ile-de-france
finalement ben oui finalement parce
qu'au début quand tu connaissais pas
j'ai osé planté pas moins de d'afrique
et exotiques
parce que les gens sont étonnés que ça
pousse dans la région alors ils m'ont
dit nous on se pose pas dit si si ça
pousse vous serez aussi présents donc au
forum des associations à
voisins-le-bretonneux et à guyancourt le
4 septembre
oui c'est ça oui vous allez aussi
proposé la bad et animations oui
un voisin parce qu'à voisins tous les
ans j'ai fait les la taille des
fruitiers pour verger à la croix de bois
à tous les ans au mois de février on a
quelqu'un qui vient nous donner des
cours dont les gens viennent ceux qui
savent tie & dye ceux qui sont
intéressés par la taille où ils
apprennent à tailler les tailles ce qui
sape affaires peuvent venir aussi parce
que on brosse aussi les troncs d'accueil
ya trop de mousse on ramasse des
branches caen s'est taillé après bon ben
il ya du travail pour tout le monde
quand ça c'est tous les ans à bazin et
cette année m'ont proposé instant à leur
forum légumes course et tous les ans on
est la barre pour l'instant
et cette année je vais faire plusieurs
animations il faut que je trouve les
bénévoles aussi
gfr les bougies avec les citoyens de
cire d'abeille on va on va rouler des
bougies après on a de l'argent dossier
pour faire l'essai pas pour pour les
bogies et apprendre à faire aussi des
graines germées ses lacets pour la santé
sas est prêt à la moto s'il est confirmé
on achète des graines
dans les magasins bio ont fait germé une
semaine avant et après on va on va
présenter les bienfaits de chaque chaque
sorte de crème j'apprends aussi parce
qu'au début je connaissais pas mais
j'apprends en avant toujours il a pas de
géant japonais encore donc ça ce sera un
forum des associations le 4 septembre
donc vous êtes à la recherche de veiller
voilà oui c'est le mot le dit oui bush à
l'arrivée d'orly aussi bien aux stands
voisins que guyancourt
ok très bien merci beaucoup on devrais
je vous en prie vous enchanter et merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette émission on
se retrouve bientôt dans un nouveau vip
[Musique]